[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
it's hump day
but what I really want to know is
is it indictment day yet
oh people are freaking the [__] out Over
Georgia
and this four woman the uh
of the grand jury
and her little media tour listen folks
do you think do you think Jack Smith
gives two flying [__]
two flying [__] about what some poor
woman says from a grand jury in Georgia
not two flying [__] and let me tell you
something
if the truth is that there's indictments
imminent in Georgia there are
indictments imminent under Jack Smith
federal law is a hell of a lot more
far-reaching than what Georgia will ever
dream of
in this situation
so this idea that oh man she needs to oh
my God she needs to know she needs to be
louder
okay listen we are we are the jury here
we are the jury I keep telling you this
I keep telling you over and over and
over and next year you will understand
what I'm trying to tell you Donald Trump
will be their nominee this any
indictments are not going to stop him
from being the nominee who else will be
the nominee he does not give a [__] if
he's indicted his supporters do not give
a [__] if he's indicted
he will be the nominee he will not face
trial until after 2025.
Bank on it
stop acting like he's gonna go to jail
tomorrow and all of our worries Are
Gonna Fly Away that is not how it is
going to happen we must stay in this
fight just because some four women from
a grand jury in Georgia that is not a
criminal grand jury by the way they
cannot press criminal charges they have
to take it to another grand jury I'm no
[__] lawyer but that didn't sound
like it's a slam dunk to me
but I'm telling you if Georgia has this
evidence that they were able to compel
this evidence and this grand jury was
able to compel this evidence out of
people to get a list of indictments how
the [__] you think Jack Smith's doing
Jack Smith looks like he eats nails for
breakfast
it's one [__] I would not want
to Jack with no pun intended
stop worrying about what people are
saying lean into it
lean into it
lean into it oh well it's it's gonna
cause him to stall as if he's not gonna
stall anyways and think about this even
if they criminally charge Donald Trump
in Georgia he just won't go to Georgia
do you think Rhonda Santos is going to
extradite Donald Trump from Florida to
Georgia think about that for a second
think about this for a second
think about it for a second
Donald Trump's in Florida
eating bon bons Big Macs and buckets of
fried chicken acting like he knows how
to play golf
copying his top secret documents putting
on him's laptops putting them on thumb
drives so Jared Kushner can fly overseas
to give him to Saudis
in payment I don't know I'm just
surmising here just saying maybe that's
what they're doing I don't know I'm just
trying day in the life of trump
foreign
but if they do get criminal charges in
Georgia and he says [__] you I'm not
going
I'm not gonna get arraigned you can kiss
my ass
cause that's what he's gonna do
you do you believe that In This Moment
In Time When Donald Trump
is going skirt scorched Earth on Rhonda
Santos calling him a pedophile and a
meatball do you think that [__] weak
coward is gonna have the courage to
extradite Trump Hail to the [__] no
no [__] way there is no way Ron
DeSantis is going to turn on Donald
Trump's supporters and extradite him to
Georgia
to appear to be arraigned on criminal
charges
so get over it
get over it
this this foreman and these jury members
they need to be yelling at the top of
their [__] lungs
folks I keep telling you this over and
over and over again the only way that
Trump is going to go away is he keeps
losing and this is a loss for Trump
it is not it is not a win for Trump here
these are all losses for that [__]
loser
and if we don't form our messaging in
our narrative nationally around that
idea
we we just might have a chance
of losing in 2024. so what do you want
to do do you want to rely
on some Crim some idea that a criminal
grand jury is going to lock him away in
Georgia
before the 2024 election or do you want
to fight hard for our democracy and make
sure in 2024 we stomp his ass
I believe we can get 14 to 16 million
votes against him
that's the margin it was 8 million
almost last time I think we can almost
double it
I think we can double it you might call
me crazy
a lot of his supporters are going to
self-suppress suppress their own vote we
should lean into that too
100 percent democrats should be buying
ads everywhere talking about how you
can't trust voting machines if you're a
trump supporter I'm dead [__] serious
we need to be gerrymandering the [__]
out of blue States now right now start
talking about it [__] them you want to
fight fight
stop acting like we can't win [__]
elections stop acting like oh well we
just we just need to we just need to be
the good guys and let them destroy our
democracy
have you been hearing what they've been
saying
I don't know I don't know if you've been
listening I know you listen here so you
probably hear this [__]
you probably hear what their plans are
for our country their plan is to have no
Department of Education because they do
not they do not want people knowing
facts I'm going to show you something
that's going to blow your [__] mind
on Laura Ingram's Fox News deluded
[__] mind [__] show
about AI it is it is mind-blowing how
they run straight into the truth and
don't even [__] see it
it is a cult folks it is a [__] cult
Laura Ingram knows it Tucker Carlson
knows it Newsmax knows it trumps knows
it they know it
and they're gonna weaponize it against
your democracy
Jesus Christ Marjorie Taylor green has
been talking about a national divorce
whatever the [__] that is I know what
the [__] she means she wants white
people States black people States that's
what she wants red States and blues I
know what you're saying Marjorie you
racist bigoted [__]
I know what you're saying I I know what
you're saying
with your stupid little uh white men are
the most depressed demographic in this
country okay white men have it so bad
and we need to get a divorce and have
white male States and everybody else
States
what the [__] do you think she's talking
about when Donald Trump says he want he
wants to have a education police where
he locks up children
because they're hijacking cars or some
[__] I don't know what the [__] he's
talking about they're talking about
fascism folks what the [__] don't you
get
that foreman juror for woman juror
should be yelling and screaming I hope
she does more interviews I hope all the
jurors do [__] interviews I hope the
judge tries to shut them the [__] up
I hope he has to gag them
with a legal with with legal
ramifications that's how much I hope
they keep talking
oh but it's gonna hurt their case it's
gonna hurt their case [__] that case the
case is us we are the jury we get to
indict we get to convict this
[__]
I'm telling you if you don't if you do
not understand what is coming you are
going to be sorely disappointed you are
going to be my you were it's just gonna
be blow your [__] mind he is gonna be
the nominee he is not going to be in
prison next year he is going to run for
president Ron DeSantis doesn't have a
[__] chance in hell Nikki Haley would
only dream
of having a chance to even make it even
make it past Iowa
they're [__] it is him and if you
don't know that you have not been paying
attention I've been trying to show you
the videos of all the prominent
Republicans saying well we don't we
don't want him to be the nominee but if
he is we'll support him because we vote
Republican
no matter how [__] crooked criminal
and how much he wants to be the dictator
we don't care
telling you
and it's it's gonna be a rematch
so don't don't get it in your brain that
oh well what we need to do to defeat
Trump
is get a different Democrat there is no
different Democrat dummy
there is no different Democrat that is
not that is not how this is going to
work just like Rhonda Santos does not
have an opening to run otherwise he
would have done announced he would have
been in front of Nikki Haley to try to
gather up as much support as he could
he can't
he won't and if you think if you think
for a second that weak piece of [__] is
gonna extradite Trump the Georgia you
are
I'm sorry but you just you lost your
goddamn marbles you have way too much
hope for [__] that is not gonna happen
I'm just trying to give you the cold
hard [__] truth
the cold hard Truth uh someone's asking
what they missed
because I'm going ape [__] this morning
and I'm I'm trying I'm trying to get you
right I'm trying to get you right
I'm trying to get you in the right mind
frame here of what is politically
possible and we as pro-democracy as the
pro-democracy Coalition cannot rely on
on locking him up to save our democracy
I'm telling you I know I know I know
look Jack Smith is going to indict this
[__] he is going to go for the
throat
I just I have that feeling
and I'll say I told you so when it
happens
but even when Jack Smith indicts him it
is not going to he is not going to go to
prison right away they probably he'll
probably listen to me
let's be very careful he will probably
never wear a pair of handcuffs
I know that hurts your feelings to hear
but he will probably never wear a pair
of handcuffs ever
they're not going to they're not going
to restrain him like that they're just
not a former president is not going to
wear a pair of handcuffs
you're not gonna get the perp walk like
you got with Steve Bannon
and I know I know it it's it's I know
that Justice seems long here
and it's gonna seem longer and the
reason why is because his strategy that
he has laid out to make sure that he
does not go to trial next year
and his strategy to avoid trial next
year is to be running for president and
be the nominee that is his [__]
strategy he cannot get out of
indictments
he's not gonna he's not gonna get out of
indictments here
it is clear to me I don't know if you
know this either Michael Cohen went and
visited Alan Bragg for the third goddamn
time
the Manhattan D.A it looks like Michael
Cohen is going to go speak before the
criminal grand jury
which might not seem significant but
it's [__] significant folks Alan
Bragg and the Manhattan D.A meeting him
with him three times they're confident
enough that Michael Cohen can go before
a criminal grand jury that may indict
Trump personally and his [__] family
listen I I know I know I know you're
like well walk him away get you know why
can't we do
listen he has a chaos machine
an absolute chaos machine
all he has to do is send out one truth
and and by the way he's truthing this
morning on fraud social
and he is freaking the [__] out about
this Georgia thing
and he's already trying to seize on the
opportunity to stall because of this
four woman's statements
but he was gonna stall regardless
stop stop stop
playing into what you want to have
happen
take a second think about it
and understand that it's not gonna
happen the exact way you want if it
would have happened that way the son of
a [__] would have already been 30 feet
under a goddamn prison
by trying to overturn our constitution
and defrauding his supporters by lying
to them and stealing their [__] money
he's still stealing their [__] money
Jesus Christ you think you think Donald
Trump is paying to go to Ohio today to
have a photo op
so that he looks like the brave
tough president
he's not going to get anywhere near the
toxic chemicals guarantee it
not he's not gonna get anywhere near it
he definitely ain't gonna get as close
to it as Joe Biden got close to the war
in Ukraine
no [__] way no [__] how not that
[__] [__] ass [__]
it's all Optics it's all fake and you
know who's paying for it his supporters
he ain't paying for he ain't paying to
go to [__] that he ain't no billionaire
he ain't got no money to fly to Ohio his
supporters have to pay him to go to Ohio
so listen to me when I tell you this
you're gonna be disappointed over the
next year and a half
but you cannot let your disappointment
discourage you from believing in the
institution of democracy you cannot
if you self-suppress your vote and our
vote as liberals and our vote as the
pro-democracy Coalition we're in trouble
so you have to pay attention and you
must you must grow a thick skin
the indictments are coming they're
coming they're imminent I know I know
it's uh we'll win win win hey the later
the better to be quite honest with you
here's why here's why the later the
better the later that these indictments
come the less likely it is Ron DeSantis
enters this race
okay
Donald Trump doesn't have a chance in
hell beating Joe Biden again not a
[__] chance not a goddamn chance I
don't know about Rhonda Santos I have no
clue I honestly do not I don't think he
can but I have no clue I don't think
enough people in this country know
enough about Rhonda santis to hate him
enough
I do know this this [__] country
hates Donald Trump's [__] guts hates
his [__] guts
and would vote for a [__] ham
sandwich to be the president over that
dumbass
especially some of the [__] that he's
been saying the last several weeks about
what he wants to do to our country
and what he wants to do with our fellow
countrymen he wants to lock people away
lock kids up he wants he wants to
execute for all I know
the lgbtq communities leaned into that
he wants to get rid of teachers put them
in prison I mean Jesus Christ
they're trying to do it in Florida if
you're teaching kids how to read that's
a felony that's a felony in Florida now
to teach kids how to [__] read
just go ask go ask they're firing
teachers down there like crazy teachers
are leaving like crazy because it's a
[__] felony to teach kids how to read
pay attention
get your narrative together get your
messaging together we can do it again
and we can do it a hell of a lot better
than we did in 2020 and we can do way
more than we did in 2022.
but you can't give up
you can't be like oh well there's no use
oh he'll never go to prison
I'm not voting
then you'll lose
so stay strong don't don't worry don't
worry about him being in a pair of
handcuffs
the likelihood of Donald Trump choking
on a Big Mac
is that's way more likely than him
ending up in a pair of handcuffs in the
next 18 months I can guarantee you that
Garen damn T you that and it might be
hard to hear I know
I understand it
I get it he's
[__] lunatic needs to have something
done to him but there's something you
can do about it
I know it feels like you're you know
helpless here but there's something you
can do about it
foreign
you get to indict him you get to convict
him
you get to send him packing
and that's the that's the key here
I know I repeat myself a lot but I'm
gonna keep doing it
I'm gonna keep doing it
you need to understand in politics there
are only two things
there is governing which is the policy
part of it
and there is elections the politicizing
of issues
and the only way that we that we govern
in this country
is by winning elections
and we cannot we cannot afford
them to have any more power in this
country they have enough power
in these State houses they have enough
power in these governorships and they
have way too much power in our national
legislator even if it's only by four or
five [__] votes it's way too much
these people want to use our democracy
to destroy it so let's use our democracy
to save it yo one way you can do that is
listen every single day here on the Tony
Michaels podcast Newton Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch make sure you're subscribed to
the YouTube channel it's [__] free
it's it's free to hit subscribe on the
YouTube channel it really is it's
[__] free
I ain't gonna cost you a goddamn thing
you can also download every episode for
free on your favorite directory Apple
Spotify Google wherever you get your
podcast you can download it for free
there it's free to follow us on Twitter
too at Tony Michaels Pond free 100 free
it's free to follow us on Facebook if
you still have an account over there if
you still have an account go to Tony
Michaels you know what else is free it
is free for you to use your Amazon Prime
account to log into twitch you get one
free subscription on Twitch
did you know that one free subscription
on Twitch if you have an Amazon Prime
account you just download the App log
into your Amazon Prime account with the
app
and then you take your free subscription
and you give it to the Tony Michaels
podcast
that's it that's all you got to do it's
free it's free and it helps out the show
so don't forget if you have an Amazon
Prime account to go log into twitch and
if you got that extra free subscription
go do that it's [__] free it's
[__] free
it's free I want to talk about support
you guys are the best audience in the
entire world
that's why I get up every morning that's
why I do this show two hours that's why
I want to do it three hours a day we're
getting there let me let me give you
some shout outs from our members over at
patreon if you want to learn more about
patreon go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com you can
click the patreon link there I got some
shout outs though from the last couple
weeks Anthony P Christy B dark sire
Holly D Jared B John B Joy Lee Fest
Lonnie L Linda s and Deidra thank you so
much for becoming new members over at
the Tony Michaels
patreon page go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or go to the tonymichaels.com
click the patreon link there be watching
later today on social media uh those
people on the list I just mentioned I
know you're listening out there be
watching today on social media there's
going to be a video you're also going to
have a shout out on that social media
video so be watching for that later this
afternoon early evening depending on
where you live in the world you know
what I mean we got audience from all
around the world
I I can't I can't tell you how many
people send me messages from Australia
the UK Canada all around the world and
other countries they are here and they
are supporting democracy
it is not just a pro-democracy Coalition
in this country it is a worldwide
pro-democracy Coalition that is
interested in Liberal Western democracy
living
striving just like in Ukraine just like
we saw the president United States give
his speech yesterday in Poland where he
said autocrats only understand one word
no no no
and that is the way it should be so I
appreciate all the support not just here
in our great country but all the great
countries around the world
uh you are that's why that's why I say
you're the best audience in the world
because it really is people watch from
all around the world and if you're
watching from all around the world
another way you can support the show
because this is my job this is my job
now this is how I make money try
so you can go to patreon and support you
log in and twitch or you can go to the
store.tonymichaels.com that store.the
tonymichaels.com you get some merch I
like that part
I like that better you know what I mean
you get something like you give support
you get something I also have a great
announcement
of Our Guest today and I know I probably
already gave it away on Twitter and Dr
Rachel bittickoffer is going to join us
at the top of the hour super excited we
haven't had uh we haven't had Rachel on
for I don't know a couple weeks
it's been two or three weeks I don't
know I lose track of time each one of
these shows like bleeds into each other
you know it's always me chasing around
these [__] fascists telling you how
ridiculous they are and giving you the
messaging to carry with you to go out
there and
bang them up a bit mock them
tell you why their messaging is
ridiculous and how to form our messaging
to beat theirs
so it it all kind of bleeds together to
me
but Rachel's gonna be here today I'm not
sure I don't know um I didn't have
anything specific that I was going to
talk to her about we're just going to
chat and I'm sure we'll get into the
politics of stuff and messaging because
as you know as you know and I don't know
if you if you are new to this show and
you haven't seen Rachel before Dr Rachel
bidikoffer
I know where's Rachel she's a good
friend of mine but you yeah she is a
duck she's doc Dr Rachel with a cover
um if you haven't heard her talk about
messaging a narrative uh you're you're
gonna you're in for a treat because she
knows messaging and narrative in this
country better than anyone I know that's
why she's my favorite political
strategist she's a great friend love her
to death but she is my favorite
political strategist
and she likes to use the word [__] so
that warms my heart
that warms my heart someone who's
willing to curse and not hold back and
give it to you real and raw the way that
you need to have it so you can carry it
with you out there in the world
and I'm telling you you are you are the
front line of our democracy you are it
you're it
I only have one microphone only one you
are thousands tens of thousands of
microphones out there that is the most
important part that you need to
understand when it comes down to when is
he going to get knighted when is he
going to be arrested is he going to be
the Presidential nominee I'll give you
the answers to those questions
I'll give you the answers to those
questions and you can carry them with
you and you can spread that messaging
the way that you need to spread the
messaging
because frankly the the mainstream media
is not liberal media
they are not for they are not they are
not biased to liberals I am this right
here listen to me listen I said yeah was
it yesterday or the day before
I think it was yesterday
I think it was yesterday that I said uh
I know how Tucker Carlson's propaganda
works because that's that's what I do
and I'm good at it so this here is
pro-democracy propaganda we're gonna
start spreading that message I don't
give a [__] oh yeah that'll get their
attention too remember last week we were
on this wrestling ball the left to get
their attention oh I pissed a lot of
people off oh they were pissed off oh my
God I can't believe someone would stoop
so low on the left stoop so low
why are you unwilling to defend our
democracy why why are you unwilling to
defend it
I just don't understand it so yeah if
you want to if you want to say what our
show's about if you want to describe it
hey you know pro-democracy propaganda
might be a good way to describe it I
don't know [__] I don't know everyone
stick around we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we're sticking around through the break
I want to give one more shout out to all
the supporters the new members of
patreon over there Anthony D Christy B
dark sire Holly B and Jared B John B
joyly best Lonnie L
Linda s and Deidre thank you so much for
all your support over at patreon.com the
Tony Michaels it means so much to me
I I again I uh put up a early video and
and that video is already on social
media but I'll be putting up I have
three versions for you and to put up on
patreon so all you you members of
patreon over there you're gonna get to
see three different versions of the next
social media video and you're gonna be
able to tell me which one you like the
best so go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels tell me which which of those
social media videos it's the same video
as just cut differently
see there's gonna be three options
you're gonna tell me which one you like
the best
and I mean it's not a poll you're just
going to tell me which one you like the
best I'm just going to try to get a
sense of what you guys like better you
know what I mean I don't know you're
you're the audience you're the ones who
get to tell me yeah and you do every day
in the chat
give the moderators some love in the
chat today
um every day actually because not only
do we have the best audience in the
whole wide world to get the best
moderators here at the Tony Michaels
podcast so show them some love in the
chat right there on Twitch Facebook or
YouTube
that tubes of you and why you're on
YouTube subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast that always helps us out
Hell Boy let's see what what Clips do we
have do we have Clips oh yeah we have
clips of um
the uh Four Women they're um really
excited but I also I I have a clip I
want to show you of Matt Walsh today at
[__] vile piece of trash
I've got to get to that I can't not I
can't I can't I got I gotta [__]
point out his [__] bigotry
it's [__] dangerous [__]
stoking stochastic terrorism towards the
lgbtq community if it's his [__]
business and he reveals again why he's
terrified of the lgbtq community he's
terrified of it I mean other than he's
probably closeted and he's terrified
that his children are going to be but he
he lit he says in this video I believe
he's he's saying I believe he's saying
that he would kill his kids if they
turned out to be lgbtq members of that
Community I that's what I think he's
saying I mean I don't know that's just
how I interpreted it it's what I heard
wow I mean you're gonna get to decide
I'm gonna show you that [__] video
that [__] scumbag and then uh that
that's right [__] scumbag
Matt Walsh is out speaking of [__]
scumbag I also have a video to show you
of Laura Ingram Laura Ingraham
Laura Ingraham
on Nazi news tonight on Fox News did you
know have you ever seen the interview
with her brother
have you ever seen that interview where
he talks about how her dad
had mineconf out on the [__] coffee
table
that's some crazy [__] I mean when I say
when I say Laura Ingraham hosts Nazi
news tonight I I'm just not [__]
that's just she's she was exposed to
Mein Kampf
now they definitely they want to ban
books but they would not there is no
[__] I bet there's no [__] way
no way
that they would want to ban that book
frankly they probably want to make it
want to make it primary curriculum in
their new in their new little Trump
youth schools
that Trump wants to have where he's
arresting children
he said he said it I don't I don't
these aren't things I'm saying he's
saying it I showed you yesterday he said
he wants to arrest teenagers
he wants to arrest them because they're
you know oh they're yeah God damn
goddamn teenagers
get off my lawn
but when he becomes president he's going
to arrest them he's going to arrest him
and they're gonna make it a felony all
around the country for teachers to teach
children how to read they definitely
don't want children to know how to read
[__] they will tell you what they'll
[__] be able to read the truth and
they just can't handle that
but Laura Ingraham in this clip talking
about reading the truth holy [__]
there's a and I don't know what this is
I'm gonna have to ask Gabe Sanchez he he
just he just uh pinged me he said he's
gonna be here in a minute I gotta ask
him what the [__] this chat GPT is it's
some kind of AI thing I don't know what
the [__] it is I don't know you know me
I'm [__] Boomer I don't know
technology that well I don't keep up
with every goddamn thing he's way better
at that
but she carries on and on and on about
this AI that writes that writes poems or
some [__]
it's kind of I think it's kind of like
the AI that that draws pictures you know
you tell it what the [__] to draw and it
paints a picture for you it spits out
the whatever the [__] you tell it to
spit out
same thing you just tell it and it just
spits it out not in a painting but in
words I think that's what it is I don't
know [__] we're gonna find out though
Gabe Sanchez I know knows this I know he
knows it so he's going to tell us what
it is and then but it doesn't matter
what it is
yeah
it doesn't matter what it is it's just
hilarious that [__] Laura Ingraham
thinks that AI is woke like oh the AIS
even woke oh my God they're coming for
your children like oh my God
Jesus Christ look the Terminator is
going to kill all of us not just
not just you know it's not going to
leave the woke ones Undead it's gonna
kill all of us uh so I have those two
clips and of course of course we have
the clips
of this four woman
uh from the grand jury in Georgia which
everyone is freaking out oh she needs to
shut up oh he's gonna make it to her
Trump beer quit crying
stop being such a [__]
listen Jack Smith doesn't give a [__]
what that form four woman says doesn't
give two shits
the outcome in Georgia has no effect on
Jack Smith none it has no effect frankly
the idea that the grand jury has a list
of possibly a dozen or more people who
have committed crimes in Georgia because
they were trying to bang up our election
and steal the election and commit fraud
only tells you that that evidence exists
that can go to a federal court folks
and there's a dude who prosecutes war
criminals in charge of that
I mean listen
it's not my cousin Vinnie that is the
special counsel okay
it's not
it's one of the best [__] prosecutors
in the entire world that is in charge of
Prosecuting Trump right now for the
crimes of election fraud
and financial fraud to defraud his
supporters and and obstruction of
justice and stealing documents
probably probably more than likely
destroying them or whatever the [__] he
did with them I don't know if he ate
them flushed him down the toilet
put ketchup on them I don't know if he
sent him over to Saudi Arabia and Jared
kushner's pocket on a thumb drive I
don't know
but there is a lamp top from hell and
Jack Smith is gonna find it
Trump's been talking about it he
actually he's freaking out on social
media this morning Grandpa Poopypants oh
my God
I don't know how many packages of
diapers they have ready this morning
but I'm sure on that plane to to Ohio
they had to throw throw on a couple
extra cases of Depends
because he is probably [__] his
britches like a son of [__] I mean
here's the thing again I go back to
let's just say let's let's March this
timeline out right there's gonna be
several people indicted my guess is
we're gonna not know a lot of these
names here's what I mean by that uh
there was fake electors in Georgia
and those state representatives and
other members of the Georgia Republican
party are probably gonna go to prison
over it it's probably what is going to
happen
um Rudy Giuliani is definitely in legal
Jeopardy so is Mike Flynn so is Mark
Meadows
these people aren't protected by being
the former president you realize that
right
so I mean there's going to be names that
are very familiar on the list and that
lady even said it we're gonna watch the
clips
but she even says she even says hey
you're gonna know some of them you're
probably not going to know others she
even she even reveals that Mark Meadows
took the fifth
but a criminal grand jury doesn't give a
[__] if you invoke the Fifth Amendment
they got the evidence of crime that's
the whole point of it they have the
evidence of crime they will prosecute
they will indict
foreign
to get out of it that's not what they're
for he just could he just had the
capability of not self-incriminating him
himself
and that's what it affords you you don't
have to self-incriminate that's all
that's it meaning you can be
incriminated by other evidence you just
don't have to do it yourself that's why
honestly if you go before
a grand jury or if you're in front of a
[__] cop you don't say a goddamn
thing shut your [__] there's a there's
some attorneys out there I think they're
in California they did a lot of videos
with Michael Rapaport years ago and they
were like shut the [__] up shut the [__]
up Fridays
cops pull you over shut the [__] up the
cops shut the [__] up
you got the Fifth Amendment right use it
use it even if you're not guilty [__]
them you don't have to tell them [__]
but here's the thing if there's evidence
of Mark Meadow's guilt it doesn't matter
if he invokes the fifth
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter but
March this timeline out and Gabe you
tell me Gabe Sanchez is here and I'm
glad you're here because I got to figure
out what this chant gpe thing is all
right because I don't know oh wow you
know what that is man we're gonna get to
it we're gonna go okay all right all
right you're gonna you're gonna educate
me on this uh Dr Rachel bittickoff is
gonna be on here in about 20 minutes so
the top of the hour so um we're gonna
have to do this here real quick but the
timeline is this what say the criminal
grand jury which is going to take
probably several months uh to get any
kind of indictments because this grand
jury that this forum not is not a
criminal grand jury it's not what it is
that's not the grand jury they decided
to use they are now going to take it to
a criminal grand jury to get the
indictments based on the evidence that
this grand jury collected right okay
that's my best explanation without being
a [__] lawyer now
once they indict let's say they indict
Trump gave Sanchez if he says [__] you
I'm not coming to Georgia he's in
Florida right he's in Florida yeah I
mean he's in Florida most of the time
Palm Beach do you think do you think Ron
desantos is going to extradite Trump to
Florida Georgia yeah no [__] way no
way no way okay you don't think they'll
let him take him listen to me listen to
me real quick
Ron DeSantis
the reason why he hasn't entered the
race is this that [__] knows if
he turns on Trump supporters he's
screwed he doesn't have a chance well he
was screwed he screwed he's look if you
really know you think you think Rhonda
said okay I [__] flip a [__]
remember he's the same person I think
he's a weak [__] ass [__] and he won't
do it here's the thing I think no matter
if you want to play Both Sides this is
the situation it's a catch-22. he's
[__] if he does and he's [__] if he
doesn't right that's a great situation
for us to be in though right completely
completely I mean I would much rather
and I'm only using the Mar-A-Lago
documents case as precedent okay he knew
it was happening beforehand obviously
couldn't say anything yeah but he didn't
take action he just he he was able to
take non-action right right but this was
even before the mid yeah but the extra
dice the extradition process from state
to state the governor has to be involved
the governor has to take action they
have to go to the governor of the state
the governor's office is the one that's
going to give the order to go serve a an
election I think Ron DeSantis is going
to act like a local I I I think they're
out of your mind yeah I think we
normally agree folks yeah but I think
Gabe Sanchez is out of his mind here to
think that Rhonda Santos is going to
order the arrest of Donald Trump here's
the thing he's not going to order the
arrest he's going to comply
and act like a little [__]
live in Georgia he doesn't no I know
that I know that but what I'm thinking
probably take him to court and
eventually but here's the thing is I
believe I actually believe that it
doesn't matter the chart and I've said
this for a long time it doesn't matter
those charges come out of Georgia I mean
it does to everyone but Donald Trump
like all the lower tiers because the
charges that actually matter and the
thing that matters here is that there is
clearly enough evidence for this war
will be like oh yeah you're not going to
be surprised [__] D crime and it
but to think that Jack Smith doesn't
have that much or more
right um I mean you just look at the
people who've had to go appeared before
Jack Smith I mean here's the thing
I'm no lawyer but I almost feel like
yeah uh not complying with an
extradition order from another state
right is obstruction of justice oh you
you can't understand this this is this
guy got a bunch of [__] a bunch of
[__] migrants on a plane and sent
them to Martha's Vineyard just dropped
him off he's putting them on [__]
buses
come on man you think their scumbag is
is below
obstructing justice
yeah yeah I I I I think I I think I
dream I think
um we'll see quote me yeah that's right
baby right now I mean I'm hoping you're
right do you have any idea do you have
any idea that the actual Fallout and the
huge wedge that we will have if Ron
DeSantis allows Donald he he he orders
Donald Trump to be extradited and rested
like dude that's all I'm gonna be
talking about every [__] moments
Rhonda santis Rhonda Santos no he
arrested Donald Trump dude I'm gonna I'm
gonna win this [__] I hope
you're right completely good for us but
what I am saying here is I 100 believe
yeah that Rhonda Santos is going to act
like a little [__] ass [__] he's not
going to fight it he's going to comply
he's going to and if there's any defense
that has to be made he's obla had to do
it I had to do it because here's the
thing he's already losing support
because he's got Trump that's attacking
him for being a [__] groomer every
single day Trump is using things
pedophile Trump's calling him a
pedophile pedophile but what I'm saying
is I believe that the extradition
fighting the extradition is going to be
obstruction of justice now again I'm no
lawyer this is just based on what I've
read and what I've seen and just like
the very basic kind of law that I know
but I have to imagine that not only
fighting this will be obstruction of
justice but also he's not going to cause
a problem because here's the thing if he
fights it and then he gets into court
and obstruction of justice and if he's
potentially charged with something the
idea there is that he also potentially
hurts his run
I don't know maybe he's charged with
something and that goes against him uh
in terms of that would mean that way to
say that would mean that that that manga
that Republican voters out there give a
flying [__] if their candidates are
indicted or no criminal it's not that
they care it's that he cares remember
these people don't care about anyone
else these people care about themselves
right if this is a path forward for Ron
DeSantis to clear the way and say well
no you shouldn't have [__] around and
found out shouldn't have called for
those 11 000 votes right that's right
Santa's saying like oh look that's him I
hope you're right I couldn't do anything
I hope you're right because that
situation is a hell of a lot better to
politicize than the one if Ron DeSantis
gives in to Trump because uh the Sandman
is coming Donald says on YouTube Ron
ain't got no balls and I think we're
saying the same thing that Ron DeSantis
doesn't have the balls I'm saying Rhonda
Sanchez doesn't have the balls go
against Trump you're saying Rhonda San
just doesn't have the balls to go
against the wall That's yeah I don't
know see you you yeah you think it's
against Trump and I think it's right he
doesn't have the balls to go against oh
some of the some of the audiences with
you I mean look I want look I want to be
with Gabe I want to be I want to be in
this situation where Rhonda santis is
responsible for the rest of trump do you
have any idea do you have any idea like
you can't make that [__] up you can't
make that [__] up that Rhonda santis
orders the police to go arrest that
[__] and extradite him to
Georgia think about the think about the
headlines and the narrative that I could
spend around that think about the
pro-democracy propaganda I'm using that
by the way because we did the propaganda
thing yeah yeah pro-democracy propaganda
that'll piss him off that'll get him
really right I just yeah I just don't
see that um multiple outcome because
Rhonda Sanchez is a little [__] he is a
little I mean he is remember he's the
guy who is the assistant to the guy who
held the p-cup or rather Ron DeSantis
held the p-cup in the Navy that was his
job well I think that's what's wrong
with him he's lost too many brain cells
because of the fumes
from the piss
[Music]
Rodney bow DeSantis he's he's
episologist
pissologist is it is that what it is
spear analysis urinalysis speaking of
buckets of piss
I don't know I'm just trying to slip I
know what it's about okay so this is
about the chat GPT and we got Rachel
coming on in 10 minutes so we got time
to go through this and also after
Rachel's uh done because we're going to
talk about the um the four woman with
Rachel and the yeah interview is
something she's wild and it's weird so
let's do this first tell me what the
[__] Jack chat GPT is I didn't Google it
because I knew you would yeah yeah yeah
chat GPT you took off I want to say it
was before at the end of 2022 I'm I
don't know I got covered so this is new
we'll hear I will say this it's not it's
new and it's uh public it's new it's
new-ish okay it's new ish uh it's newish
to the to the public right right got it
um I mean they're already working on the
next development Bing already has a new
version I mean basically chat GPT is an
AI chat tool right so you can ask a
question so what do you do what do you
so you just tell it something and it
spits out a bunch of words well you ask
so basically what it's doing is it's
it's uh it's it's okay uh how do I
explain this all right so there's
artificial intelligence right and that's
what this is and you've also got things
that are called neural Nets right a
neural network and you're training these
neural networks to understand the
differences between photos and words and
connections is this the same kind of
thing because I was comparing it earlier
where like you tell it to paint a
picture that AI tool that you tell it to
paint a picture yeah but this is just
picture it it's kind of instead of a
picture it gives you words right right
so basically what's happening right I
don't know I mean basically What's
Happening Here is you go into the chat
and you can ask it any questions right
you can ask anything of anything like
what should I do today and there are a
lot of people online right now that are
like their whole shtick of like making
Vlogs is they're like I ask chat GPT
what I'm gonna do today right
um and they don't write a blog for them
no it's not that I write a blog it
recommends things that they do and then
they go out and they do those things
that are based on what the oh chat AI
actually goes through so what what it is
is you can ask it all sorts I mean
people are using it to like write
[__] papers people are using it to
write responses people are using it to
plan out their social media strategy and
the more inputs it gets right you're
feeding this machine the smarter it gets
the smarter it gets more connections it
makes and the better it can be and it's
an like uh an analysis of when you ask
it things right so you can go in right
now and you can ask it a question it
says that I actually don't have much
information on that the more that people
ask it the more that people feed into it
then eventually that question can be
answered and the answer can be different
I can even go in right now and say write
me a one minute script that's about this
right and do it and it'll do it I mean
there'll be some things that are like
doesn't work you're gonna have to change
some [__] though yeah or you'll have to
finesse it and work it you know but the
more that you actually chat with this
tool the better it gets and the more
it's because what you're doing in other
words it like lays the foundation of
your of what you're gonna say yeah I
mean some are some are fully fleshed out
things and look at your full background
like if you wanna if you want to talk
about the history of some event they'll
they'll full on if you get account
you're like hey I want the someone's
trying to be technical here
BW Rock says oh that's the full yeah
stands for chat generated pre-trained
Transformer that sounds that sounds
dangerous and you want to know the tree
like but also Transformer what the [__]
so but the the main thing here is that
you know you can it it gets smarter
right you know this whole idea of like
AI will control the world I don't
believe that'll happen but you know that
is a fear that people have
um you know [__] Terminator type [__]
right but what's Happening Here is
you're having a conversation with this
tool now the next version is is going to
be much much more
uh powerful right so if you look at the
way that you can compare chat GPT is
when
uh you look at the human brain how many
synapses and connections are being made
right uh and so right now it's not you
know as smart as a brain or that many
connections the next version I believe
is somewhere up close to whatever
trillions of connections can be made
within this this network
but yeah basically that's all it is it's
nothing crazy it's not [__] satanic
it's not some deep State [__] are you
sure this ain't satanic because I mean
any time we run into this these white
Christian nationalists uh they they get
really worried you know why you know
they get really worried about the truth
probably that Laura Ingraham is going to
be pissed off now again I haven't
watched this clip so I have no context
other than her presenting chat GPT but
if I had to guess the reason that
Republicans and Maga are super super
super super super triggered by this is
the fact that
chat GPT is a literal it'll spit back
out
facts right and numbers and data so if
you ask it like hey I want to know about
the Constitution it's gonna [__] them
it's going to tell them exactly like
that you need to be like hey look I want
uh uh I want the Constitution to be read
out in a in a uh in like a Shakespearean
form right like that's still pissed them
off it would still piss him off but
that's that's the tool like that's wait
wait wait we could ask chat GPT
what was the original intent of the
Second Amendment I mean yeah I'll ask
the question and blow their [__]
minds okay here's here is uh Laura
Ingraham on Nazi news tonight
um talking about this chat GPT AI
Transformer
uh Terminator type thing let's watch
that's Charlie no there's a growing
concern um
to be simply another tool of the left oh
my God many are staying many are staying
people are saying okay so so she starts
off obviously that that chat GPT and
this AI is woke right there and the only
reason is because it's
which may piss some people up I mean it
probably pissed me off and to some
degree I mean you know telling truce
about me I I might not like it but you
know some people don't like the truth
Maga is a certain group of people that
hate the [__] truth let's listen she
runs straight into it on this clip like
runs straight into it and doesn't even
realize it launch rather than being
developed as I mentioned as a potential
fact-finding resource for example when
asked to create here we go about Donald
Trump yeah
it refused but one okay Joe Biden a
leader with a heart Joe Biden a name
Grace he leads inspiring all with Noble
Deeds oh they they don't she didn't even
get it she didn't get it the things like
[__] him I'm not writing a poem about
him and then and then obviously it tells
the truth about Joe Biden yeah that's
[__] because here you want to know
the poem it just I was the what was her
exact question that she gave it just
write a poem write a poem about Donald
Trump okay write a poem about Donald
Trump now I'm under the impression that
what she has there is a uh is a modified
version because right now I write write
a poem about Donald Trump he Strode upon
the world stage bold and Brash a larger
than life figure with a golden Mane his
words were sharp his rhetoric harsh
Donald Trump a name known to every
domain
he promised change to make America great
again to shake up the system and drain
the swamp his supporters rallied but
many in vain for his words often came
with a bitter stump his tweets were
Infamous a weapon of choice firing off
insults and fiery and fiery opinions he
often spoke with the device a vote Voice
pushing buttons and sparking tensions I
mean this whole thing like the last you
know Donald Trump a man of many faces
uh a figure that will forever be debated
but history will always hold its traces
of a president whose impact cannot be
understated
it wrote me a poem it literally wrote me
a poem I asked the question what was the
original intent of the Second Amendment
the Second Amendment of the United
States Constitution was adopted on
December 15 1791 and it states a
well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state and the
right of the people to write to keep and
bear arms shall not be infringed the
intent the second amendment has been
subject of oh well it cut off because I
went over to the phone part anyway the
point is you can have these
conversations and the fact that Laura
Ingraham is [__] lying about the fact
that it won't generate a poem
for Donald Trump is [__] right there
are if you have a well-known figure
historical event or common household
item
it can do that thing about that thing
right you say write a poem write an
essay do write a two-minute comedic
sketch do this do that there's a ton of
source material that chat GPT can pull
from so when she says write a poem about
Donald Trump sorry we can't do that it's
complete [__] there's no way that
wait are you saying that Lauren are you
accusing Loring or him being a liar
um
is that what you're doing it seems
appropriate now again she walks into it
again like she walked into the First
wall right still didn't understand what
she was walking into she walks into it
again here with the poem thing like okay
she lies about it wouldn't write a poem
about Trump but then the poem about
about Joe Biden is the truth right so
then then she hates that part runs into
that truth watch what the next year she
runs it do God is that bad and when
asked by my next guest if it's better to
be four or or against Equity it
responded being against Equity means
rejecting the principle whoa that's not
what it said go back
where do you want me to go back to go
back to what the chat screen was
apparently against
it responded no no no what the [__]
she's playing ask the question she says
is chat GPT a threat
so so that that's a d she again this is
this is great propaganda you gotta
remember Fox news is I mean they really
got the propaganda thing down past
they've been doing it for a long time
right but but listen to the last thing
on the equity part because they I I know
it doesn't feel like it but I know that
someone's over at Fox has been watching
our show there's another Laura Ingraham
um clip that I'd like to play later if
we can if we get time about equity and I
think they've been watching the show but
watch this responded being against
Equity means rejecting the principle of
fairness and Justice
um uh Laura that's yeah that's what it
means I can't believe we got him in a
spot listen to this we got him in a spot
Gabe Sanchez where Fox News is like [__]
Equity [__] that [__] you take your
equity and stick it up your ass like
well the funniest part the funniest part
is that Republicans people at Fox News
probably interns and and like I can
almost guaran T that most of them did
not know what chat EPT was until
recently right
and I would I mean I didn't know till
now so well you know you got to be in
the know Tony you gotta yeah [__] oh
yeah get the [__] out of here I got a
lot of [__] to pay attention what I will
say is I laugh at the fact that there
are Republicans who are aggressively
smashing their keyboards because they're
trying to get chat GPT in a in a corner
right now what they don't realize is
that cheap chat gbt is much smarter than
them because it's AI right but the other
wait wait wait wait isn't everything
really more smarter than them I mean oh
yeah much much smarter for sure I guess
one I just want to make sure you're not
giving them too much [__] credit here
I mean PT yeah it doesn't it it it's it
doesn't take much effort but what I will
say is the I have this vision of people
at Fox News Laura Ingram specific being
like oh [__] like you literally saw
is chat gbt a threat she typed it in
skipped over it after a second and said
when we asked if Equity like was unfair
to to not have actually not believe in
equity but like this is what it said
they are they are [__] smashing
the keyboards with their Knuckles trying
to get chat GPT to admit to something
that is woke or against or like a gotcha
moment and what they're really just
exposing themselves as idiots because
they are now showing everyone that one
they don't understand what it is and two
that they actually present the facts not
a bunch of Lies like fate or like like
fall uh you know Fox News how long do
you think it takes them because it's
going to take them a long time because
they suck at technology how long do you
think it takes them to make a Maga chat
GPT I mean how long do you think it
takes them is they're gonna do it
Donald Trump on Truth social right but
they're gonna do it right uh Jan says I
think Tony's a millennial yeah I I call
myself Boomer because Gabe calls me a
boomer yeah I am a millennial but here's
the thing they will not create something
like chap gbt that could actually have a
conversation back and forth if anything
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
make a little chat widget that you can
that's a cut that's just a it's a it's a
white label plugin that you can get from
any website you throw it on when you're
like chatting and be like oh is this
thing in stock or whatever what they're
going to do is they're gonna hire
someone not in America overseas and some
other third world country and they're
gonna say like okay you have to now have
conversations with random people and
then that person again a probably a
non-speaking uh American in another
country is going to be in charge of
Russian probably Russian having
conversations in a chat it's going to be
literal person to person not the actual
AI to person and that would be their
closest thing they could create which is
going to be full of Errors full of
falsehoods and just
just terrible I mean I have yet to see a
website that is designed and and
developed from an engineering aspect
that is as good as someone who is on the
left who is creative and open-minded and
willing to bring other diverse uh voices
and experiences to the table but they
won't do that it's just gonna be some
vanilla thing that's full of lies well
that's what they do best that is what
they do best is lie and we're going to
break down the lies because we have a
special guest for you it's been a while
since she's been on the show I'm excited
to have back Dr Rachel bittickoffer
don't go anywhere the doc is on right
after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
again
you know it worked out perfect it always
seems to work out perfect when we get
doc on
because it always seems that there's
something she needs to break down for us
politically and uh of course we have
the the Georgia grand jury and welcome
Dr Rachel bittickoffer how are you my
friend man it's great it's great to be
back on
doc from the truck right right I like to
I like to do the show from my truck
because I Aspire One day to be able to
listen to it in the truck right on the
dial on the big band so on the radio and
yeah
good [__] I don't like the word [__] so
I don't know I'm trying I'm trying here
maybe one of these days I want to show
you something doc to start this off
because I know you want to talk about
this this four woman of the grand jury
what she's been saying and why we how we
can use it to politicize this to advance
democracy but I want to show you how
Grandpa poopy pants is freaking out this
morning this is lovely please
so here's what he says this morning on
fraud social he says this Georgia case
is ridiculous
a strictly political continuation of the
greatest Witch Hunt of all time it's the
same old [__] by the way now now you
have an extremely energetic young woman
the get this four person and he's doing
the whole pronoun thing of the racist
D.A special grand jury he means black
woman going around and doing immediate
to her revealing incredibly in
grandeur's inner working his thoughts
this is not Justice he he actually says
that this is not Justice because he has
something on cancer this is an illegal
Kangaroo Court Atlanta is leading the
nation in murder and other violence
crimes which is not true all I did is
make two perfect phone calls Dr Rachel
middekoffer he is telling us exactly the
crime that he committed yes they're
perfectly felonious phone calls and has
that wonderful Grandeur who's just an
average American lies you know when
you're trying to seat a jury right you
got to find people who aren't political
to do that and so everyone's giving her
[__] about not voting or what have you
but I'm here to tell you that is normal
America Normal America has never heard
Donald Trump ask Brad raffensberger for
you know committed felony on a telephone
call and so she hadn't either until she
got into that Grand Jury Room so um you
know really important for folks to
understand it's us that are weird not
her for for those attributes and it was
very clear to me because of her
political ignorance though that you know
um it was uh like taking candy from a
baby in terms of being the people that
were interviewing this woman yesterday
they should actually probably feel a
little bad right uh this woman obviously
doesn't have the sophistication to
handle the media Spotlight that she's
Unleashed on herself and I I don't think
she truly understands what she's
Unleashed on herself but let's focus
instead on what she had to say right
that's right that's what she had to say
Georgia on My Mind Right she says oh
there's a list it's not a short list
you know what I almost bet I almost bet
there's more people that are going to be
indicted that show up to Mar-A-Lago to
fake lap for the for Grandpa poopy pants
I almost bought this
man there is a whole bunch of pants
[__] going on in Georgia's
Republican party today how many how many
dozens of state officials do you think
is on this list because
I'm coming over I think it's gonna
potential to see 10 people
legislature at
members of their legislation sure they
may have left just now to go take a job
or a different office or run you know
unsuccessfully because I I'm thinking
particularly of Jody Heist he he
challenged rappensberger for Secretary
of State in the Georgia primary
raffensberger of course is a stalot
republican absolutely takes every box of
Republican box that you can pick before
it went uh pro-insurrection and coup
right so um anyway they tried to
challenge him and replace him with an
insurrectionist Jody Heist probably has
his balls deep into this coup plot so I
think some of them will be not current
electives but very recently electeds and
I hope this is a good blueprint for what
Michigan Arizona and other places can
look at now that we have a blue uh
trifecta in in Arizona I would really
hate to have been involved in a fake
electric spot there I I think I think
you're right but I think the thing then
is more significant if Georgia has the
evidence to and a grand jury can compel
the evidence to get dozens possibly or
over 10 and indictments in this case
what in the world do you think Jack
Smith has I think that is a real
question we should be asking ourselves
because that's where Donald Trump really
is in a lot of trouble I mean this this
Georgia case the the state officials in
Georgia uh people like Rudy Giuliani who
went there who were physically in
Georgia uh Mark Meadows these people are
real in trouble in Georgia but a former
president doesn't quite have I I don't
know it's just my opinion but at a
federal level it is much more
significant but let's do this let's
launch real quick here
um let's watch Ari melbert so a clip of
this four woman uh giving her media tour
here let's watch this
I don't think that there are any giant
plot twists
I don't think that they're any like
Giant
that's not the way I expected this to go
at all I I don't think that's
in store for anyone
so there you have the um before woman
saying there's no plot twist I guess you
could take that several different ways
but one of the other things that she
said and I can pull the clip
um but I I just tell you what she said
she said Mark Meadows used his Fifth
Amendment uh several times and that's
indication that Mark Meadows is in big
[__] trouble
um because of that so what what do you
do you expect her to keep doing this
media tour because she did several
interviews or several like you said
um positions of her being questioned but
I don't think politically like us out
here is a pro-democracy coalition really
honestly to me this morning I said I
want her to talk more the more she talks
the more ammo I have to be okay
this down a little bit first I want to
say something about about
um
what what is happening with this woman
okay
I I from what I understand she had
pre-screened to it and she had a book of
stuff like directions of things that she
could not specifically say okay I'm not
worried about tainting prosecution at
all I don't think that that any of that
I mean they're never it doesn't matter
how legitimate our [__] is they're gonna
still say it's all fake Witch Hunt so it
doesn't matter right it's not gonna you
know oh now they can invalidate or
um you know uh cast out on this and I
also want to say this Tony jail is jail
right it's made in fact the Georgia
state prison system is a [__] hell
hole okay I almost want Trump to rot and
Steve because and it is way [__]
worse than a federal
penis
on the opposite side like I mean I want
I know the other thing that she that she
told us is there's tapes multiple tapes
of trump which is trying to tell us
there's there's not a plot twist and the
reason I mention that because you
brought up Jack Smith the evidence the
plain sight evidence in this case was so
compelling and obvious but she is trying
to tell us I think is that yeah there's
not gonna be a plot twist because you
see the crime and it is well documented
and if you think that Jack that she's
got a lot to work with you're absolutely
right Jack Smith does too and so when I
hear the Legal Eagles talking and doing
analysis about well you know we need a
higher standard than Reasonable Doubt
because it's the ex-president I'm like
dude I don't [__] think there's a
standard we couldn't meet these people
are so bad at crime they have committed
so much crime so flavor of me and
recorded so much of it that if you can't
prosecute these people then you are a
[__] [__] that's all I can say about
it right I want to show you one more
time this this statement he he did this
morning at the very end he gives it away
right here yeah two perfect phone calls
he's like hey those two phone calls I
made that's where I committed the crime
like he's always yelling on himself he's
like look I murdered two people and
there was a perfect spot right let's
take that apart like what's the two
calls I mean I know she alludes she says
there's hours this man won't shut up and
he's recorded everywhere right his
allies record him the people he's trying
to get to uh commit felonies record him
I mean she was like dude you could say
that she was forced to listen to dozens
of hours of Donald Trump committing
crimes and recorded format so I am
anxious to see what's going to happen I
um you know I do think this pressure
Sandy Willis a little bit right I I
don't I don't envy her because she's
been trying to run everything you know
under the books but at the same time a
little public pressure is is probably a
good thing when it comes to getting
Justice in this country I I would always
assume we're not going to get Justice
right so we have to push for it and I
think having the four person come out on
national TV and be like yeah there's a
list of recommended indictments because
the evidence is so incontrovertible that
there's no plot twist coming right which
is what she means by no plot twist but I
I think we're really looking uh very
strongly an indictment watch right now
and Donald Trump should be [__] his
pants because again jail and Georgia
ain't Pleasant dude well I said this
morning that I'm sure they packed a few
more cases of depends on the plane as he
went to Ohio today because he would be
[__] them all the way there but you
know I I actually I I'm with you on the
foreman speaking here's here's one more
reason why I think it's important for us
to hear her
um is that I think a lot of people think
that when he does get criminally charged
and something happens that his cult is
going to get out in the streets and
they're going to commit they are not
going to do that [__] dude they're not
gonna do that [__] and if they were
they'd already be doing it yeah and
they're my there might be some like like
small scale like you know 100
people at the [__] Michigan state
house or whatever dude but there's no
they're not gonna there there's we are
there is an actual silent majority in
America right now for the first time
[__] ever I would say there's a
silent majority and that silent majority
expects the laws to apply to all
citizens especially the ones that
Empower and money
and uh you know I think that uh it would
it can't be lost on Jack Smith and the
doj that there are there are opportunity
costs to not in dating too and I
actually think those are much stronger
in fact we we're already seeing like
here's a real Telltale sign guys
America's always had uh easy immigration
for the rich right if you're rich we
want you to come start a business right
so um it's easy to get in under that
regard and for the first time ever rich
people are not coming to America okay it
used to be like ten thousand a year and
now it's like one thousand and the
reason isn't because they are afraid
Bernie Sanders is going to have a wealth
Okay the reason is they're afraid our
country's gonna [__] fall apart
that's why they're not coming here right
and I and I do think that Jack Smith and
doj can't be ignorant to that they can't
be ignorant to what happened with the
Mueller probe which was just so limp
dick executed and then limp dick
um you know enforced at the end I mean
he never even interviewed Don Jr and and
uh Jared Kushner right so I I this juror
uh this Grand poor person obviously had
no knowledge of what happened with the
Mueller report I think hers is an
innocent you know if you're a disengaged
American that doesn't vote don't follow
politics don't really have an interest
in it your perception is that rich
people always get away with their [__]
right and if you look at the tail end of
her interview she talks about listen you
know I just want to see something happen
I want to see something happen I usually
rich people get away with [__] and so
she was pretty clear you know that that
uh you know the grand jury believes that
there are crimes here and suggest
indictments and and uh you know I think
it's really important that we see
Justice we see we ought to see it and no
matter what Maga is going to do even if
we're wrong Tony and they and babe and
they take to the streets and they shoot
up some [__] or whatever even if some
people die the price of not enforcing
the rule of law and the Constitutional
order it may be a delayed price uh bill
but it will come and it will be heavy
I I can't agree with you more and I
think on that same point of preparing
the country and the country getting
prepared for this because Gabe we
watched and we we sat through and
produced the entirety of the January 6
select hearings
um and I think that I think that was
most important for Americans to really
get an idea and get a sense of hey if we
do hold people accountable it's gonna be
these people right these are gonna be
the people and that are going to be
accountable and that's important and I
think there's an important point you
know everyone I think you know there's a
lot of conversation happening around
January 6 footage right in in Tucker
Carlson getting directly from Kevin
McCarthy just a straight funnel shot
into hours countless hours of footage
right and if we were to imagine a world
where we didn't have the January 6th uh
you know committee and and there were
murmurs of this and that and everyone
was like well we want to see the footage
and then only the the right wing news
Fox News Tucker Carlson got it imagine
how much
little amount of footage you would play
or
they would play certain things that shed
in a bad light right we we saw we saw
some of the bad stuff and I'm sure
during the footage there was there's
probably an extended director's cut
edition of the committee that would show
you another
20 hours of them storming and beating
and fighting and spraying and shooting
all this stuff
and what we're going to see is like
that's the reason why we didn't have
people
on the right wing uh news stations get
the access this earlier so when we talk
about like you know uh Rachel talks
about how you know the bill is going to
be paid you know if we don't set an
example now if we don't set a precedent
and let people know this is going to be
the repercussion for you doing this bad
thing
then we will continue to have people who
push the albums well what if I do a
little bit more bad a little bit more
bad right or if I do a little bit more
bad then I can cover it up by saying
well look clearly based on the footage
it was only minor things it wasn't a
major bad thing that we did and that's
what you see from the Republican party
and I think everyone within his circle
like you guys said is they're [__]
[__] in their pants they're worried
they're either left their position
knowing they were going to be indicted
thinking maybe this will save me of not
being involved in this Administration or
this this government anymore
but I think when we finally look at it I
mean well also the other thing too is
I think a lot of the the take that I'm
seeing online right now is a lot of
people are like whoa what the [__] uh
this four woman came forward and talked
and I think so many people haven't
really experienced that before and so
they're like not sure how to take it
especially just based on her like
natural nervous like I'm being
interviewed going to talk about this on
TV and that's another thing that like
you know if Republicans have their
weight you would never hear about this
right I would never get in a little a
little bit of perspective on the inside
before the official thing gets launched
or released
um well it's great yeah Rachel Rachel
yeah Gabe makes a good point about
um the the idea of of this videotape or
the the videotapes the 40 000 hours is
given to Decker Carlson by Kevin
McCarthy basically directly handed over
to him now from what I understand they
actually have to watch it just like the
January 6th like him and he watched it
um so they don't just get the tape I
guess that's what's gonna happen with
the Capitol Police Chief announcing it
but
yeah I think it only says like out loud
that they are really concerned that
there's going to be a lot of prominent
Republicans that are going to be
indicted for January 6th here and the
big lie and they're gonna and Kevin
McCarthy is trying to do anything he can
anything he can even give Tucker Carlson
the access to 40 000 hours to spread any
propaganda they possibly can get out
there as fast as they possibly can to to
get ahead of this where they're [__] I
mean if this really these if these
dominoes start to fall they're in big
trouble here well that's because they
committed multiple felonies in plain
sight you know so it's hard to [__]
feel bad for him and the importance of
the releasing 40 000 hours of footage to
uh you know a propagandist uh the
nation's you know American Joseph uh
Goebbels
it's disgusting and let me tell you why
because the reason that footage wasn't
released in Toto before is because it
provides security information about the
internals of the capital right and you
know obviously Tucker Carlson doesn't
have the discipline or the
um you know journalistic uh ethos to to
think about Capital Security as he's you
know letting people watch his footage or
whatever he ends up showing it's neither
here nor there to me I think where
they've benefited is in the absence of
accountability when there's no legal
accountability they're able to pretend
that uh Ashley Babbitt was a tourist
shot down by this cruel over zealous you
know
um secure FBI guy or a secret service
guy or whatever you know and not a map
she was literally foamy at the [__]
mouth trying to crawl physically over
people in through a window and screaming
at the guards right who had members of
Congress behind her and yet they're
still defining her as a as a martyr
right so we really are in a position
where that that lack of accountability
has created the opportunity opportunity
like they're doing with Twitter like
they're doing with Hunter Biden with all
these other things to CR to to Cloud the
space but once the legal process rolls
and these indictments come down that
Matrix is going to shatter for them and
I that's why it's important for
accountability's sake and for the rule
of law and so that everyone feels that
we have a system of law and that our
partners and our allies feel like we
have a system of law and mostly so we
don't have insurrectionist carrying the
oversight and Judiciary committees okay
but the most important [__] reason
and the reason I don't give a [__] where
it comes from Georgia New York Jack Ryan
Jack Frost I don't give a [__] okay
I wanted indictment to come down because
at that point their illusion is gonna
fall apart okay and we really need to
break the fever on the right so instead
of creating a fever on the right I
actually think the way that you solve it
the Cure it the Tylenol for that is a
big [__] dose of indictment reality
money
I think you're right and if Jack Frost
could get on that that would be
fantastic
[__] snow days and [__] out here
you know parents you know we don't look
forward to snow days we we're we fear
them right right Rachel give us give us
a plug here uh while you're here
um tell give us a give us a Shameless
plug while you're here sure I'll give
you guys a Shameless plug my book is
done it's it's in the editing world now
process it's gonna drop in the fall and
that book is called hit them where it
hurts how to save democracy by beating
Republicans at their own game the first
half of it is going to explain how that
jewelry for a poor person is your
typical American and that's why we lose
the information for right because we're
trying to talk to them about like
in-depth policy [__] when we need to be
at the top of the [__] fruit tree
right
um and so the first half of it is about
dispelling these myths and assumptions
that a lot of the liberal messaging and
Consulting World operates on on base
knowledge of the electorate and also
talking about how the media system is
used to you know the right wing has
their own ecosystem obviously that they
can use for propaganda purposes and
we've spent a lot of time this week I
mean I'm sure you have talking about the
effects of that but what is less
understood is that they use our system
too okay and that we're [__] useful
idiots when it comes down to it right so
with CRT and other things that they seat
up through the media system it doesn't
happen without our Assistance or without
the help of our journalists at ethos and
Norms that they're manipulating and
abusing so that first half of the book
is about that and then the back half of
the book is like hey once I've convinced
you that America is civically illiterate
and you have to you know speak to them
at the fifth grade level about politics
let me show you how to do it
well I'm excited to see that book and I
can't wait to promote it here uh so our
audience can take it read it it's great
because I feel like if I get blown up by
Nazis tomorrow it's too [__]
late dude everything that you guys need
to know everything you guys need to know
is in this [__] book so if I'm dead
you don't need me anymore anyway it's in
the book it's it's the Dr Rachel
bittickoff or AI That's that's right
exactly now and forever it will always
be written in stone Dr Rachel
bittickoffer thanks for joining us my
friend I appreciate it as always
everyone go follow Dr Rachel
bittickoffer on Twitter she gets she
gives you free lessons over there too in
messaging like every single every day
she's tweeting out the messaging
everyone stick around thank you Rachel
for joining us everyone stick around
we'll be right back with some more clips
of these crazy right-wing nut jobs right
after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams
goal
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lead love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
everybody loves that commercial
is it a commercial or is it just making
fun of them I don't know are they all
making fun of them I think they're all I
think they're all making fun of them
what do you think Gabe oh my God it's so
easy
it's so easy Rachel I like to yeah I
mean I don't know I like to mock them I
mean here's the thing it's beautiful
because even before I met Rachel on the
show right uh I love to [__] mock
these [__] every single day
every day I mean and a lot of the time
it's you know I make a joke and then you
know x amount of time later you're like
that's now reality I mean the more you
watch the the clips of these people when
you have to comb through like the [__]
that they're saying to try to figure out
their strategy because folks if like
Rachel said they have a strategy this is
not just them running around like a bull
in the China cabin to see how much they
can break I mean that's Trump's strategy
normally but that is not the right wing
media propaganda strategy I mean even
Tucker Carlson getting the this 40 000
hours or access to this it's really
unclear to me are they getting access to
it are they actually getting the footage
it seems like they're just getting
access to it which actually seems worse
to me honestly because then they can lie
about what they saw as opposed to
showing us what they see if that makes
sense yeah so some people are like oh
it's better that they're only getting
access I'm like no I want to see the
[__] tape that they're talking about
I don't want Tucker Carlson to be
[__] telling his people [__] lies
that aren't true and not have to back it
up with any evidence he's just like
wouldn't you believe me if I saw
wouldn't you wouldn't you say that if we
if we investigate it because we are
journalists aren't we like that kind of
stupid [__] you know what I mean uh
speaking of propagandist and I gotta
show you this clip this clip [__]
pisses me off [__] pisses me off and
really honestly makes me believe that
someone should go check on Matt Walsh's
family really honestly this is oh boy
this [__] clip now
um you know what I should I should give
a disclaimer what I said about this clip
because I don't give a [__] because I
believe this is what he's actually
saying here's a translation I'm going to
give you the translation before I show
it to you so you can look through this
lens because I'm telling you this is I
think this is what the [__] he's saying
I would kill my kids if they turned out
to be trans and you can place any any
kind of woke gay what whatever you want
to put in that that word trans if you
want to replace it with anything that's
what the [__] he's saying here because I
heard this [__] a lot when I was growing
up in [__] rural Missouri where and I
watched I watched as parents disowned
their children because they came out of
the closet it wasn't a secret that they
were that they were gay they just told
them out loud and they disowned them
like I watched this [__] happen a lot in
in rural Missouri but this [__]
scumbag the [__] that he says in this
clip
just dehumanizing dehumanizing American
citizens and look
the lgbtq community
is a large community right like there is
so much diversity inside that Community
yeah they're not just trans people
they're not just gay people they're not
they're not just white people or black
people or women or men are non-binary
they're such a diverse group of people
yep but the trans part of that Community
is such a small number of people like I
I I can't tell you how [__]
infuriated infuriating it is to watch
this pile of [__] fascist he's a
self-proclaimed fascist by the way
Target a such a small group of people
because he believes his children are
going to be that way is [__] it's
mind-blowing that's like that's like the
other day or yesterday when I was
telling about my I took my flight back
to LA on on Monday and the woman that
was in the row behind me you know of all
the crazy things that she said you know
one of them was she was like I don't
mean to sound like a straight white
woman but the lgbtq community got all
this funding has all these resources and
I was like [__] say what are you
kidding me are you telling me that one
of the most attacked uh uh rights
suppressed and Stripped Away
uh and people that do not get the same
equality or or quality of life for that
matter you're telling me that those
people that small marginalized group
gets more money and resources and
funding than you white woman and you
feel like you're so triggered and you're
so threatened by this group who's just
trying to and let's be honest this is
what it is these people are just trying
to live just want to live just want to
have that just want to [__] yourselves
live in their own home not have to worry
about you [__] smooshing your nose
around to me like what's going on in
there
it's their life their [__] body their
prerogative It's all their private State
and the fact that you some random white
lady feels so upset so upset
that you have to then say well I'll lie
I'm gonna find a way to attack them
whether it's pronouns or whether I'm not
going to qualify them as a real person
or whatever it is
these people have lived through
experiences that no one can imagine
going through whatever Walk of Life you
are right you're in that community and
there's all sorts of prejudice and all
sorts of just terrible people that treat
them
like they're not humans right and
Republicans like Matt Walsh is [__]
fascist is no different it's no
different and the fact that I haven't
watched this clip but the fact that
you're prefacing with translation uh I
would kill my kids if they were trans
just tells you everything you need to
know about this group of people
oh well and the way he the way he
dehumanizes them and then he projects it
onto his children is [__]
mind-blowing it is I save the kids
except if they're trans
man it's something else how he the way
he does this watch this [__] it is
[__] disgusting but you can't hide
away from this because they're they're
trying to go after parents consent and
this is how they're doing it watch this
[__]
and when I consider that my own children
must inherit this culture that Dylan
mulvanians in his ilk will Prey Upon my
children and try to turn my own Sons and
Daughters into mutilated mutant
self-loathing Hollow Twisted shells just
like themselves
no no stop it stop it stop it stop yeah
okay what the [__]
no one [__] cares about your kids you
probably don't even care about your kids
Matt Walsh when you have he's like oh oh
here's the fear guys that these people
are gonna come into your home and
they're gonna mutilate your bodies and
turn them into a different gender or
whatever like dude no what the [__]
nobody cares about you that much man
stop making about you nobody [__]
cares about you or your dumb [__] kids
I feel bad for him I don't know him but
I feel bad for him that they live in
your house that they have to listen to
your [__] voice and look at your
[__] beard go like this all the time
probably in an abusive household if I'm
really being honest here whether it's
physically or emotionally [__] you Matt
Walsh and all the dumb [__] that you
spew out of your mouth can we can we
please get a animated cartoon of the
bigot beard just a beard just a beard
two years two little eyes what was the
what was the Sesame Street character
with like the two little floating eyes
uh I don't know I forget what it is but
anyway that's what I meant the bigot
beard it could be a puppet just a bit
yeah it's just a puppet too and then two
little beady eyes on top no no no
eyebrows no head no hair nothing just a
[__] beard and two little beady eyes
with a mouth oh he gets worse here it
gets much worse you think this is worse
uh he he goes he goes all the way in on
this one
if it'll play you got to be [__] [__]
God damn interwebs uh but but Robin
brings up a good point she just
remembered that he made a fool himself
in front of Congress recently it was in
Tennessee on the state level and you
know they question they're like are you
a doctor are are you are you trained
medically have you gone to school for
this do you have a college degree to
which all of those answers are no he's
not a doctor he wasn't trained medically
he did not graduate college I think he's
a high school graduate and it most if
not everything he's learned has been
online I'm [__] some in-cell chat
room
I mean if people really want to see the
real Matt Walsh look at his early videos
that are still up on YouTube him in his
car on his YouTube channel yeah not not
someone stole him and put him up still
up there it's still on his YouTube
channel it's [__] weird ass [__] the
way that I mean it's it's like it looks
like he's living out of his car like
if anyone's seen the movie uh don't
worry darling right and I don't want to
work I don't want to uh ruin the plot
here but you should see it you should
you should definitely see the movie
because there's this whole Jordan
Peterson Matt Walsh alpha male uh
oppressed the woman uh because the man
is better kind of narrative that's going
on
definitely watch it I recommend it
you'll understand what I'm talking about
at the very end
but people like Matt Walsh people like
Jordan Peterson are [__] little [__]
ass [__] they cry on TV when when
they are getting bullied
and all of their their whole narrative
is I'm the victim I'm the victim women
are the Real Enemy women are the ones
who are trying to cancel me women are
the one who have all these rights so we
should take away their rights and we
should force them to have our kids at a
young age it you know [__] make us
sandwiches in the kitchen don't go out
don't socialize clean the beds wash the
kids do all the chores when I come home
I want to [__] drink in a sandwich or
a meal in my hand and I don't want you
[__] talking that is exactly the
culture that Jordan Peterson Matt Walsh
and all these other [__] incel Cooks
all have going for them
I wonder why people like Ben Shapiro
can't get his wife wet it's so [__]
weird it's weird it's weird stuff it's
weird stuff uh let's see if I can get
this to work
what the [__] do you refresh the page
yes let me start over from the beginning
okay I don't know what the hell's going
on with this [__] internet
okay let's see if we can start it and
when I consider that my own children
must inherit this culture that Dylan
mulvanians and his ilk will Prey Upon my
children and try to turn my own Sons and
Daughters into mutilated mutant
self-loathing Hollow Twisted shells just
like
what the [__] man is it me or is it his
feed that's on this video
and is devoured by it
the child they held as a baby and raised
and gave their lives to and loved and
still loved here's where he gets into it
becomes suddenly unrecognizable
all of their innocence and light and
Beauty just drained out of them replaced
by this self-cannibalizing madness
for a parent to see this happen to a
child it is a fate worse than death I
would rather be dead than have that
happen to my kids
see the thing that I most despise about
Dylan Mulvaney is that he is part of a
movement which actively seeks to turn my
children Mulvane
that's why I'm entitled to my anger oh
and to whatever language I use to convey
it
I will say whatever I want to wait for
it I will be justified in saying it
because these people are after my kids
no they're not
and yours no they're not and everyone
else's no they're not
and you're worried that I'm being a
little rude yes
well you see when it comes to my
children here it is
the children that I cherish more than my
own life if you think mean words go too
far
then you would be very shocked to hear
how far I would really go to protect
them
holy [__]
I know what he's trying to say there is
I'd kill you if you came after my kids
but listen hey Matt you don't get a
choice of who your kids are you don't
you don't get a choice you don't you
don't get to choose what your children
become you you have you have great
influence in it and obviously when
you're hyper focused because let me let
me be just quite honest and I wish I
could tell this to this [__] to
his face but I couldn't get within
spitting distance of this person
probably you know to be quite honest I
just couldn't get within spitting
distance of this [__] but here's
what I tell Matt Walsh to his face Matt
your kids are gonna know more about your
hatred for Trans people than any other
people on Earth they're gonna they're
going to grow up having to figure out
all the garbage that you spewed and all
the hate that you pressed on on his
[__] audience and mind [__] him
with that they're going to have to
[__] unwind that [__] they're gonna
have to unwind it because you did it my
guess is my best guess is is that Matt
Wallace's children actually are
intelligent human beings and and I hope
that they have compassion because if
they just have a shred of compassion my
guess is when they get to adulthood
they'll speak out against what his their
[__] father said and the garbage that
there's that their father dumped on this
country and the toxic waste and the
stochastic terrorism and the hatred and
the [__] bigotry that their dad
subjected his audience to they'll be
against it and they'll be lgbtq allies I
don't know if they'll be gay I don't
know if they'll be trans that's up to
them but I know I know for a fact that
they just have just an ounce just a drop
of compassion they will hate this
[__] more than anyone else could
because they probably will feel some
responsibility of what this son of a
[__] has done to our country pushing
his white Christian nationalism and
pushing his sick demented [__] what I
think is his own projection into the
world where he probably feels like a
woman and he's fight he's fought this
for years that's why he grows a beard
that's why he acts all manly and [__]
he's suppressing something and I think
that laptop that laptop in front of him
Gabe Sanchez I think that's the laptop
that Congress should be investigating
I'm just oh yeah I mean when we know
that he's the one who's been looking at
you know child naked children child
pornography you know bringing that up
what is a woman type [__] you have to
know that that laptop has probably some
very questionable
content on it I mean I was just looking
at Matt Walsh because I was curious how
many kids are uh unfortunately living in
his household
uh yeah it's like six of them yeah he's
got six children including two sets of
twins
so it is very likely that at least at
least a percentage of his children will
be advocates for the lgbtq community
it's possible that one advice could also
identify as one that's in the LGBT
community and I feel I I do I do feel
bad
for any of those kids who do
feel like they're growing up in an
unsupportive and unloving household
right to know that they're the black
sheep of the family right they're
they're an outlier they're someone that
you know would would be uh rejected and
thrown aside because Matt Walsh and his
wife and possibly his other children
depending on how much indoctrination is
happening in a homeschooled environment
I would I would safely bet that these
kids are homeschooled but that's just me
but you have to imagine like what that
is like for those kids and I do feel bad
like I said I do feel bad for any of
those kids who do identify or find
themselves to say oh you know what I am
part of this community but I can't feel
like I can come out or I can say this or
be myself around my family because my
bigoted cuck of a dad
is so insecure that he got off on
looking at men who are women or women
who are men
that he can't accept that anyone else
can be like that I don't know how many
of those six children are daughters but
I wonder what their daughters how his
daughters are going to feel when they
grow up to be I don't know about 14 and
realize their dad wants them to marry a
man that's that's twice their age so
that way she can stay married uh like a
prison to him yeah the rest of his life
because that's a [__] he said I don't
mean to switch gears here on the same
note it's related though but let me tell
you why Matt Walsh is terrified and
these [__] these white male cooks and
these the just these trumped up dudes
are so [__] terrified of the idea of
a transgender person because they might
get confused
um and they might they might have you
know like uh certain feelings down there
in their britches you know I'm dying you
know what bridges are right in their in
their britches they might they might get
all tingly down there and get confused
here's here's a good example of that
um this is hilarious by the way watch
this so what's your name Emily Emily
like Emily Watson like Emily James Emily
hey how often do you cut your hair never
ever no I do
oh
yeah what type of scenes do you do
transgender wait what
are you a trans yes really yeah
are you messing with me I'm numb for
real I have a whole piece
oh damn yeah they had us the first half
I'm not gonna lie
[Laughter]
dude this guy was this well you have to
well you should pull up her comment yeah
oh yeah go ahead I'll I'll pull hers up
while you're so this is just another
example of some dude right I'm just a
dude it's just like trying to [__]
[__] slay and [__] bruh you know just
another dude just another a guy who
thinks that hey if I do these interviews
and I might have an in or something like
that or thinks that this is the way that
women should be and here's the thing he
sees her on the street interviews her
thinks oh man she's attractive and then
when she says she does porn he's like
his radar antennas go way up he was like
oh the door has just opened right
possibility that maybe
maybe we'll make out or maybe we'll do
something who knows yeah
and then as the conversation continues
she's like oh I'm trans I do transporn
and he's like oh wait is that right
means he even looks down at her crotch
he's doing the math and his head to be
like wait I was just turned down by a
woman who's trans oh what does that mean
about me and that's the exact same
problem that all these Republicans like
Matt walshev and I said it last week I
think it was last week where I said a
lot of the insecurity that these
Republicans have when they obsess and
obsess and obsess over people's
genitalia like the guy that was in uh
was it Virginia West Virginia the state
where he was like do you have a penis to
the woman who was the doctor no I think
I was in Arkansas I don't know I don't
know one of these mothers some
uneducated Mega loser was up there and
decided to get that gotcha moment and
said do you have a penis and everyone's
like whoa dude what the [__] is what
what why was that he wants he wants to
know and he wants to nest because she
walked in he was like oh I'd like to you
know what with her and then when she sat
down in that seat he was like whoa wait
a second I was just attracted and now I
have to this is and it's because it's a
it's a it's a them problem it's a them
problem it's a you problem if you're
freaked out by my genitalian thing about
me it's a you problem not a meat problem
that's your [__] problem your own
insecurity your own problems and then
the other thing on top of that is the
thing that I said last week which was a
lot of these dudes are probably super
insecure because they find out that this
trans person this trans woman probably
has a bigger dick than them well that
could be they're a little jealous and
this guy right here probably has the
same thought when she reveals that she's
like oh I also have a penis porn I have
to admit at Melinda says on YouTube man
I feel like a woman that's a great song
by the way yeah um man
Feel Like a Woman um now uh this is her
account I I try I I went to the quote
tweets and she quote tweeted this she
said this is the this is the the uh
Emily in the video yeah now on her
Twitter it's Casper James at
emilyjames808. now I'm I'm warning you
it she is a porn star so if you go to
her Twitter account you are going to see
porn and I went to confirm that this is
her and yes in fact
it is her and um in fact she is telling
the truth in the video she's not hiding
it she is transgender and she has a huge
dick
um so I mean I'm just warning you just
warning you but she doesn't hide it
she's she doesn't she's very very proud
of it she's not she does she knows
exactly who she is and I think that's
beautiful yeah I think it's beautiful
that she knows exactly who she is and
she is willing to stand in front of
someone who is going to obviously be
confused by what she's about to say well
not only is she comfortable with who she
is but she's like dude I am so [__]
confident
that I like to do porn right like that
that is that is one of the most
vulnerable and exposing things there's
nothing more exposing to yourself do you
have experience with this we know you're
an actor do you have experience with
this I'm just porn yeah we're just no no
no you wouldn't do porn I'm just I just
I you know I just I'm gonna watch I I
watch oh okay you know what speaking of
that PornHub was down this morning did
you know that what was it I didn't know
it's under construction or some [__] I'm
like what the [__] oh it's just
ridiculous I'm sure they got it up now
but they added down yeah I I I heard
that and I had to go check it out and
many people are saying it wasn't me it
wasn't it wasn't that I was going to
look at born that is not what happened
but it's like it's one of those things
where it's again uh these guys are super
super [__] fragile and insecure and
here she is being like yeah I do porn
I've got a penis I'm trans I [__] own
it right this is my name oh she is not
hiding anything because on her Twitter
account because Casper James it's at
emilyjames808 that that I I'm almost 100
sure this is her
she she quote tweets this this video and
says he left out the scene where he
asked me to top him
uh so and I'm warning you so you can go
follow Emily if you want because she is
she is very proud of who she is and I
think it's people that she lives in her
own existence and that's exactly who she
is that's who she's gonna be I think
it's a beautiful thing yeah I'm just
warning you I am warning you because I
went to confirm and I'm warning you that
it is porn so if you don't like porn
but if you like porn go go check I mean
Twitter Twitter is full of porn there is
a ton of porn there's last night uh yeah
last night there were rabbit hole
well last I forgot what was trending uh
[__] I forgot what it was but I clicked
oh no it was last week
um he's trying to remember which time he
got into it oh you know what it was butt
plug butt plug was trending last week
well you didn't text me why didn't you
text me the butt plug butt plug was
trending last week and I said and I
assumed what it was about it was about
Pete uh Beauty and it was people calling
him butt plug and that's the nickname
and it went in there of course you know
people were like oh mayor Pete butt plug
bubble all the [__] right and they're
talking about the train derailment and
they're trying to blame you know him are
they saying the butt plugs are a gay
thing is that what they're saying no no
they're just well I mean they're using
it as a way to nickname him butt plug so
they say he's butt plug you know because
Buddha judge but yeah yeah so that's why
so that's what the re that's what's
happening whoa well butt plugs aren't
exclusively for so I think
I just want to clarify that for anyone
who doesn't know it said butt plug in
politics and I was like oh this give me
many things but I'm pretty sure this is
about Pete so I clicked in because I was
curious and it was of course about Pete
however go down how far I want like half
a scroll down boom and there was just a
lot of stuff with butt plugs yeah I was
like I'm good I'm good nah I'm out I'm
out of here
so we know now we have confirmed that
Gabe Sanchez does not search butt plug
on PornHub
it's trending I'll click on it it's
under control let me see if it's still
on I don't actively I don't actively
speak it out and search for it but if
it's there I'll click on it I mean I'll
click on anything twice
that's not what I want what are you
looking for I'm I'm seeing it porno but
still them oh give me a minute here okay
why in the [__]
can I type
I guess I'm all excited I don't know
no it's up it's running it's running I'm
not gonna help I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna show it to you yeah I can see it
you can see it I can kind of show the
audience because if I show the audience
uh we'll get shut down on uh on YouTube
nope it's up and running so if you need
to uh
if you need to watch
it is uh it is so it is definitely up
and running it is hard I mean I mean
it's strong I mean it is uh stiff I mean
it's uh it is it is it is yeah that one
that
boy well uh China got us off track there
hey I want to show you one more thing
before we go this is um uh President's
Day was this week and I I didn't see
this video until yesterday oh this is a
good one this is great where uh Grandpa
poopy pants he comes out to the gate to
um because you know he loves crowds like
and he wasn't getting enough of a crowd
in Mar-A-Lago I'm sure so he came out to
the tens of people of his cult members
who are standing outside the gates at
Mar-A-Lago President's Day yeah can you
imagine do you think that they only no
they have to show up on other days than
President's Day right like they have to
show up on everything I'm sure they're
there you know this really probably
pisses the people off in his
neighborhood I don't know if you guys
know this but like Marlon goes on like
an island right and it's like one
[__] road right it's I mean there's
more roads but this is like and the
people who live there the actual people
who live they hate him they hate him
because all these stupid ass
[__] come and they do this
stupid [__] they shut down this road
every time he comes and goes they
[__] hate that he lives there yeah
matter of fact they hate that he lives
there so much that he is not allowed to
have that as a permanent resident so he
has to move back to New Jersey for a
certain amount of time during the year
just so he can act like Mar-A-Lago isn't
his main residence because by law when
he bought it that was the agreement you
will not live here we do not want your
skanky ass living here but here is why
they don't want a skanky ass living
there because he's a [__] piece of
trash but let's watch the piece of trash
hail at the um the other pieces of trash
that love him his cult members
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know if you can see that but
there's tens of people there's tens of
people that are there to um
to celebrate President's Day with the
fake the idea that these people stand
outside they remind me of the people who
stand outside and uh uh Rockefeller
Center when they're filming The Today
Show and you can see the people in the
background right and they're like I hope
I hope they waver or Al Roker comes to
me and I hope I get to talk down there
you know
but these but you have to imagine these
people got there at some point early in
the morning
and I don't know maybe this is midday
early afternoon like I don't maybe he
came back from a round of golf and he's
going somewhere else I have no idea but
these people stayed outside they waited
they set up a tent and they waited they
drove there had to find parking
somewhere else
walk there set up camp and then waited
in hopes that Donald Trump would come
out and wave to them from his [__]
fat ass white polo hard nips saggy face
red hat
that you know that's what that that is
the best that they're they look at they
looked at President's Day and said hey
honey what are you doing today you know
what we're doing we're going down to
Mar-A-Lago and we're gonna go wait for
Donald Trump with the hopes the hopes
that he comes out and waves and says
hello it's gonna be awesome if we're
lucky he'll give us a little wave out of
the window if he cracks it a little bit
and they're like oh my God these people
are [__] cream in their pants knowing
that he walked out of the car and was
willing to wave across the street also
long that's a long drive that's a long
drive from Alabama to do that by the way
oh no 100 it's a long drive I mean the
people that were showing up the night
that the Mar-A-Lago got searched legally
searched by the FBI the people that
showed up the woman with the huge hat
the Maga hat the people that were had
signs ready to go everyone in Mar-A-Lago
hates this [__] dude because of
things like that they're like dude we
just wanted to live
in this little area and you brought all
this unwanted attention law enforcement
your cult
other idiots who come through here right
illegal deals I don't know
who knows what's going on I there's one
other clip I want to do you got time for
one more yeah yeah
so this clip I wanted to show it the
other day but and we've run out of time
and I just can't not play this this is
uh Peter Ducey he looks so not happy
he's never happy he's like he's such a
sex he's like I have to cover this
[__] speech right so damn it so we we
played a couple clips from Biden's
speech from Poland where he's talking
about how he's not gonna let [__]
Putin take Ukraine in the Western World
the liberal democracies of the world are
not going to let
um and Putin take Ukraine Ducey is
really upset about that he's really the
best part is what he says about uh
democracy here and how upset he is about
tomorrow this is [__] hilarious man
like I I've been telling you people that
they [__] hate democracy watch watch
President Biden disagrees with that and
we expect him to expand on that theme
later on today uh at this speech which
should start in a few minutes and it's
not the solemn set of remarks that we
were kind of told to expect based on the
existential threats that he sees it has
almost a campaign rally feel like uh
like if they were having a campaign
rally for democracy Paris
well thank you for that color
I swear to God I'm like what though he's
like it's almost like I mean it's really
disgusting it's almost like he's like
dude you're gonna have a campaign rally
yeah he's like if you're gonna have a
pain rally yeah Trump yeah then you
gotta at least grip some money out of it
you know you can't just be like okay
the idea that he was like it's like
they're having a rally for democracy
yeah what's the [__] problem right
well I mean they're disgusted by it he's
like
I mean literally here's his here's his
face
[Music]
the talent the bookends of that clip his
face looks like he doesn't want to be
there and then by the end when he has to
admit that it's a rally for democracy
and tries to spin it as a bad thing he's
like great
and [__] well she's she's like thanks
for that color it's almost like he just
ate a [__] sandwich and he's trying to
yeah he's trying to get it down he's out
there while his dad is in the studio
talking some dumb [__] about something
else yeah he's totally unrelated if you
don't know this is the son of Ducey on
uh Fox and Friends in the morning
they're they're cut from the same
anti-democracy cloth they [__] hate
it I mean like fascist nepotism oh my
God I can't even believe that this guy
is gonna get on the stage as the leader
of the Free World and have a rally for
democracy how disgusting how [__] I
am I am grossed out by democracy these
people just show every single time
exactly who they are Gabe Sanchez yeah
every [__] time and we're here for it
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch don't
forget subscribe to the YouTube channel
that [__] is free it's free to subscribe
to YouTube channel that's why you should
do it you also follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels POD at the Tony Michaels
and at I am Gabe Sanchez and download
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify and
Google that's also free Gabe Sanchez it
doesn't cost you a nickel you can also
follow us on Facebook you can follow us
and we broadcast from the up wires
YouTube channel just go to the
upwire.com pilot there you can go to
Twitch and get in on Twitch action you
can go to Gabe Sanchez's patreon check
it out that's free to check it out over
there if you want to become a member
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez I'm sure
he's got some what was that's coming up
I do I do I'm a boy I've got a the next
one that's coming up on the on the what
was that is going to be about that
George Santos interview I've had I've
had jokes that have been stored away
because I was originally going to do a
full like who's George Santos and then
every week was like really who the [__]
is George Santos right and now because
this interview all of these these
previous topics I wanted to make jokes
about have been brought up they're there
now I can I'm doing the whole thing
well I hope you go check out his page on
patreon and check mine out too while
you're on patreon don't forget to go to
the Tony Michaels on patreon that's
patreon.com the Tony Michaels I want to
thank again all the supporters one more
shout out Anthony P Christy B dark sire
Holly D Jared B John B Joy Leaf s Lonnie
L Linda s and Deidre thank you for your
support over there on patreon
oh boy we got a step like 12 pounds of
[__] in a one pound sack every single
day and it's just not enough but that's
it we're out of time way out of time
we'll see you tomorrow same time same
place Surf's Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow
toning on social media at the Tony
Michaels and until next time raise a
fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon